The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So, let me start
here with the temperature
dependence of k.
And this turns out to be
extremely important.
And it's due to Arrhenius
in 1889.
And Mr. Arrhenius is famous
for many reasons.
Not just for his rate law.
So I learned recently, turns
out that he was also one of
the first people to calculate
the potential effect of carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere.
And and its potential effect
on global warming.
This was the Industrial
Revolution and people were
starting to use fossil fuels
at increasing amounts.
And back then, already, some
people started to get worried.
And so he did the calculation.
It was a very crude
calculation.
And he extrapolated, assuming
that the rate to fossil fuel
use would keep going,
he got his
calculation pretty much right.
What he didn't get right was the
amount of fossil fuel that
people would be using.
And so when he did his
calculation, which is again a
very crude calculation, he got
that we would get in trouble
at about 2,000 years from the
time of his calculation.
So he said, no problem,
2,000 years, we've
got a lot of time.
And ever since then people have
redone these calculations
and more and more
sophisticated.
But his crude calculation
was good enough.
And as people redo the
calculations, the time that
they say we're in trouble to
the time of the calculation
gets closer and closer
together.
And the reason for that isn't
that their calculations are
wrong, it's that the rate at
which we put out carbon
dioxide just keeps getting
faster and faster and faster.
So it's interesting to go back
to these calculations through
the last century and a
half and see that.
Anyway, so Mr. Arrhenius
predicted global warming.
And he wrote his rate equation,
k is equal to e to
the minus Ea over RT.
Famous Arrhenius
rate equation.
If you plot it as log of k is
equal to log A minus Ea over
RT, you find that it looks
like a straight line.
With an intercept at log A,
where A is the pre-factor here
and Ea is going to be the
activation energy.
And the slope is Ea,
minus Ea over RT.
R is the gas constant.
T is the temperature.
And if you put in some typical
numbers, activation energies
typically are on the order of
a few tens to hundreds of
kilojoules per mole.
Let's say 50 to 300 kilojoules
per mole.
And typical activation
factors, typical
pre-exponential factors, are
depending if it's a first
order or second order.
Let's say, first order 10 to the
12th, 10 to the 15th, per
second, so the A carries the
units for the rate here.
So if you have A, so this is for
first order, if you have a
second order, then the units
of A will be different.
And typically they're going to
be on the order of 10 to the
11th or so, 10 to the 10th, 10
to the 12th, one over molar
per second, for second order.
And it's interesting to do sort
of a back of the envelope
example to figure out how
important this rate is.
And one of the interesting
things to look at is, suppose
that I'm at some temperature
and I want to know how do I
change the temperature.
How much do I need to change
the temperature
to double the rate.
And let's say my temperature's
at, say, T1 is on the order of
300 degrees Kelvin,
room temperature.
Room temperature, and let's take
a typical Ea on the order
of 100 kilojoules per mole.
Room temperature, or body
temperature are roughly the
same, right?
These things are.
And so the question is, what
does T2 need to be to double
the rate connected with an
activation energy which is
fairly typical of 100
kilojoules per mole.
So we want to know, what is, if
I have k2 over k1 is equal
to two, what's the new T2.
Alright so A e to the minus Ea
over R T2 divided by A e to
the minus Ea over R T1, we want
that equal to two, the
A's cancel out.
So log k2 over k1, which is
equal to log two, is equal to
Ea over R, one over T1
minus one over T2.
We know what this is, we know
what this is, we solve for T2
and we find that T2 is
305 degrees kelvin.
It's a pretty small change
to double the rate.
So it's pretty important that
your body temperature doesn't
change very much.
If you have a fever and your
temperature goes up, rates
start going up.
In your body, you could cause a
lot of problems if the rates
of some reactions go up
by a factor of two.
So, very sensitive
to temperature.
Rates are very sensitive
What are these things
physically?
Ea and and the pre-exponent
factor.
Let's take a look at that.
So physically what's going on
is, you have your two, let's
say it's a bimolecular reaction,
A plus B goes to C.
So mechanistically what we think
is happening is that the
molecules come together
and collide, right?
You have A and B getting
together and colliding.
And the hypothesis
is that when they
collide they form a complex.
They sort of bind together
momentarily.
And form this complex that has
all the kinetic energy, or
part of the kinetic energy of
this collision as part of it.
So A and B are bound
together in some
highly excited complex.
Which then falls apart to give
the product by rearranging its
atoms around.
And if you plot the energy of
this process as a function of
the reaction, we call this the
reaction coordinate, then
we're going to start at some
delta G, or some energy.
For the reactants.
We're going to end up with some
energy for the products.
And it could be higher
or lower.
Let me make them higher here,
just because I don't have
enough room on the board.
Products.
So if this is an endothermic
reaction, that's the energy
for C, this is the energy for
A plus B, and then along the
way we have this complex that
captures some of the energy of
the collision.
Up here somewhere.
And this is the energy, then, at
A B star, which we call the
activated complex.
So for the reaction to happen,
then, we have to go over the
barrier and then back
to the product.
And this distance from the
energy of the reactants to the
top of the barrier, that's Ea.
That's the energy
of activation.
How much extra energy you
have to put in there
to go over the barrier.
So it's very clear that as you
increase the temperature and
you increase the amount of
energy that the reactants
thermally have, or in terms of
their kinetic energy, as you
raise the temperature you get
more and more kinetic energy,
you're going up higher and
higher in the Boltzmann
distribution.
And the number of reactants
that can make it over the
barrier clearly goes
up exponentially.
As the temperature goes up.
So this is Ea for the
forward reaction.
Clearly there's going to be an
equivalent activation energy
for the backward reaction.
The two are related.
The difference between the
forward and backward
reactions, so E backwards minus
Ea forward gives you the
delta G for the reaction
itself.
So, Ea backwards minus Ea
forwards gives you delta E for
the reaction.
Where E could be enthalpy or
it could be free energy.
So that's the physical
origin of this Ea,
this activation energy.
Now, A, the pre-exponential
factor, that's the rate of
attempt for the molecules to
try to go over the barrier.
So it has units that make
sense for that.
And this A is different than
this molecule here.
Rate of attempt.
How many times per unit time, or
how many times per second,
do these two molecules
try to collide?
They never collide, they
never try, they'll
never make it over.
So it's one over second, or
one over mole second.
So this is the rate
of attempt.
Then e to the minus Ea over RT
is the probability of success,
of making it over the barrier.
So the rate of attempt times
the probability of success
gives you the rate
per unit time of
making it over the barrier.
Any questions on the
dissection of this
Arrhenius rate law?
Alright, so here's some
examples, a few examples that
you know of.
Let's look at OH minus
plus methyl bromide.
Displacement reaction going to
this OH minus attacks the
carbon right here.
To form an activated complex
H, H, H, with the OH
coming in like this.
Let me go like this.
OK, there's the intermediate
right here.
The activated complex
in your reaction.
Which then falls apart.
It can fall apart two ways.
The OH can be spit out again,
forming back to the reactants,
or the bromine can be spit
out, forming the product.
Which in this case
here is methanol.
H, H, H, OH, plus Br minus.
Typical example.
So, given this picture here,
which you're probably already
somewhat familiar with, we can
then move on to talk about how
to affect this barrier.
How to change the rate.
Oh, I should say a couple
more things.
One more thing, too.
Now, the rate of, so clearly
the Ea's are related.
Because the difference of the
two Ea's is the delta E for
the reaction.
But the pre-exponential factors,
these A's, for the
forward reaction and the
backward reactions aren't
necessarily related.
You can imagine that in one case
you have, first of all
they don't even have to
have the same units.
You could have a bimolecular
reaction one way.
And a unimolecular reaction
the other way.
So you can't really say anything
about the forward
versus the backward
rate this way.
All you know is about
the energies.
OK, catalysis.
So now we have this barrier
we have to overcome.
And, so suppose that you
have two motivators.
Suppose you have an equilibrium
case which is slow.
And a reaction which
is slow in both
directions, k1, k minus one.
And you don't want to wait
for this to happen.
And this could be in a
biological environment.
Or it could be an industrial
process,
like the Haber process.
You don't want to wait.
And so one of the ways that you
can speed it up, you know
is by changing the
temperature.
You change the temperature,
the rate goes up.
You change it by five degrees,
the rate goes up
by a factor of two.
You can make a huge change by
changing the temperature.
But, so if you raise
T, speeds up.
But, K equilibrium
also changes.
And we saw that when we
did the Haber process.
We raised the temperature.
The rate speeds up, but
the equilibrium
switches to the reactants.
That's no good.
So changing the temperature is
not always the best thing to
do if you want to
change the rate.
Instead, what you can do
is use a catalyst.
if you find one.
A molecule that reacts with
your reactant to form a
product, that's B, spitting
back that molecule C again
without using it up.
And now with the activation
energy, we can understand what
the catalyst does.
What the catalyst does is speeds
up those rates, k2 and
k minus one, by changing
the activation energy.
By making the E smaller.
So now I have a catalyst,
and I can
make this energy smaller.
So this would be A plus A C
activated, getting ready to
spit out B.
So in my example here where
I have A plus B goes to
products, so I would have A,
some combination of A, B, and
C together, to give
out the products.
In this case, the difference
in energies doesn't change.
All that you're changing is that
the hump, in both ways.
Equilibrium constant
doesn't change.
Just the rate changes through
the Arrhenius rate law.
And this is extremely
powerful.
Especially in biology.
So let me give you some
examples here.
This is sort of a typical
example of increasing rates.
Let's say you have the reaction,
hydrogen peroxide,
goes to water plus oxygen.
If you take a little bit of
hydrogen peroxide and you put
it on your skin, it
starts to bubble.
But if you let it sit on the
bottle nothing happens to it.
Put it on your hair, your
hair turns white.
Blond.
But again, if you just
let it sit in the
bottle very little happens.
Well, it happens but very,
very slowly over time.
So if you look at the rate of
this reaction here, if the
rate, moles per second, with no
catalyst at all, the rate
is 10 to the minus 8
molar per second.
Which is very slow.
And the activation energy in
kilojoules per mole, in this
case here is 71 kilojoules
per mole.
Now we can start adding
catalysts.
We can start adding inorganic
catalysts
like hydrogen bromide.
Increase the rate at
10 to the minus 4.
So this creates a complex with
the hydrogen peroxide, which
lowers the barrier to 50
kilojoules per mole, a small
amount of lowering.
But because the energy is in the
exponent there, it makes a
big change in the rate.
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The rate is
independent of the catalyst
concentration.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The rate would
have to change.
You're right.
That's a good question and I'm
not prepared to answer it.
I'm going to have to
think about this.
Let's pretend now that we are
at per unit concentration of
the catalyst.
And then, and I'll
look into it.
OK, so this is what happens with
an inorganic catalyst.
And instead if you use a generic
biological catalyst,
an enzyme catalase, it's a sort
ubiquitous enzyme which
is why you have it on your skin,
et cetera, then this
rate become 10 to the 7th.
And the activation energy
drops to eight
kilojoules per mole.
So your question really has to
do with the units of A. Of the
pre-factor right there.
OK, and so there are all these
examples of reactions.
That are very important
biologically.
Where with an inorganic
catalyst, an organic catalyst,
you can change the
rate by maybe a
few orders of magnitude.
But as soon as you put in an
enzyme, the rate changes by
ten orders of magnitude.
Or in this case eight
plus seven,
fifteen orders of magnitude.
Humongous change in the rate.
So you've probably done some
enzyme catalysis before.
But it's probably a good idea
to quickly do it again.
Because it's just
so important.
And it ties together our
approximations that we've
learned about.
So enzyme catalysis, so enzymes
can be either, could
be heterogeneous catalysis, can
be homogeneous catalysis.
Enzymes are ubiquitous in the
biological environment.
They serve to regulate the
cellular activity in very
complicated ways.
The cell will up-regulate
or down-regulate the
concentration of enzymes
as it needs to make
more or less products.
And there's whole cascades
of events that
happen in this way.
And they're in very small
concentrations.
But they play an extremely
important role.
Because they're also
extremely specific.
So you can have an enzyme that
will only act on one part of
the biological cycle.
And affect it by 10 orders
of magnitude or
15 orders of magnitude.
But not affect any other
protein that's around.
And that's amazing.
And it turns out that a lot of
the diseases of old age like,
what I'm about to face, or am
facing already, you, not yet,
but, are the result of some of
these enzyme up-regulation,
down-regulation, beginning
to break down.
So we have all these reactions
going on that need to be
essentially perfect.
When you have DNA replication
or protein folding,
or things like this.
And errors are made.
Errors are made all the time
in these processes.
And errors cause diseases.
And so, even as a baby,
your biological
processes make errors.
But you have these processes,
these enzymes especially based
on enzymes, that can go in there
and sort of fix things.
Fix things and make sure that
you don't end up getting
Alzheimer's at age six months.
But as we get older, for some
reason, these repair processes
lose their bearings.
Just like we lose
our bearings.
And and they can't repair
things any more.
They don't do it very well.
And that causes all
sorts of diseases.
Cancer is probably one of the
diseases, due to the lack of
being able to repair problems.
Alzheimer's.
All sorts of dementias.
MS. Just name a chronic disease
and it's probably due
to a problem with
up-regulation or
down-regulation of some
proteins, some enzymes, that
are due to a repair process.
So anyway, these enzymes
are big proteins.
10 to the 4th, 10 to the 6th
molecular weight proteins.
On that order or so.
They tend to be fairly
large in size.
On the order of nanometers.
Let's say ten nanometers
to 100 nanometers.
That could be, that's a little
bit on the big side.
Probably closer to
ten nanometers.
Ten nanometers is kind
of big, for any sort
of biological molecule.
And they always end with
their name ase.
Like catalase, uriase, rnase.
Esterase, clips ester bonds.
Your liver is full
of esterases.
Because it likes to break things
down into smaller and
smaller pieces and lots of ester
bonds and things that
are not very biologically
interesting.
And that's one way of the liver
breaking things down.
So the way it works is that you
have your reactants, which
in the biological language are
called your substrate, come
in, into an enzyme.
Gets bound up in a pocket
of, there's
the substrate, reactant.
There's the enzyme here.
Forms a complex.
And then product
gets spit out.
And the product floats off.
And does its thing.
It probably gets bound to
another enzyme, which makes
another product.
Et cetera, and the
cascade goes on.
The signaling cascade goes on.
And this enzyme is in very
small concentration.
The product goes away, so that's
going to stay as a very
small concentration as well.
So let's observe experimentally,
then.
Experimentally, what's seen is
that the substrate makes
products in the presence
of the enzyme.
With a rate dP/dt, that's, at
t equals zero this is the
initial rate is proportional
to the
concentration of the enzyme.
This is initial rate.
And in the language of enzymatic
kinetics, this is
called the velocity. dP/dt is
also called the velocity.
Velocity, moles per unit time.
And this would be called, then,
the initial velocity of
v initial. v initial's
proportional to the enzyme
concentration.
And what else is seen?
For fixed, if I fix my
concentration of enzyme, I
look at the velocity over time,
let's say minus dS/dt,
which is dP/dt, I find that
that's proportional to S. For
small S. Small concentration
of substrate.
And then at large
concentration, it's a constant.
So it's not a straight line.
In fact, I don't want to do
it on this board here.
I'll do it on this board here.
Plot the concentration of
substrate on this axis, and I
plot the velocity, or the
rate, of the reaction
on that axis here.
What I find is that
it's a constant.
So it's going to saturate, the
rate is going to saturate to
some number.
And it's going to start
linear with
substrate at the beginning.
So it's going to be a straight
line at the beginning.
And eventually it
will saturate.
That sort of slope.
And the saturation point, that's
the maximum velocity,
or maximum rate that
it can have.
So we call this v max.
And this part here, the velocity
is proportional to S.
And somehow we have to
find, explain this.
Using what we know
from kinetics.
So we have to come up with
a mechanism, and
then solve the mechanism.
And make sure that it
reproduces the data.
So we're not the first ones
to do this, obviously.
Michaelis and Menton did
this many years ago.
For this mechanism.
And the idea is, you have the
enzyme plus a substrate react,
k1, k minus one, to
form a complex.
Enzyme substrate complex.
But unlike what we've drawn
before in terms of this hump,
where there's an activated
complex which is not stable,
in this case here this enzyme
substrate combination lasts a
long enough time that it's
basically a stable complex.
So we're going to write this
as a real intermediate that
lasts long enough for you to
be able to fish it out.
And characterize it.
And then eventually, that, k2,
k minus two, goes to product
plus enzyme.
So the enzyme is a catalyst
that forms
a long-lived complex.
And if you were to draw this,
then, in our energy diagram,
where we have the reaction
coordinate here, you start out
with your enzyme
plus substrate.
Go up, and you form your
intermediate up here.
ES.
And I put a little dimple in
there, because it's stable
enough that it's not on the top
of the hump, but it lives
long enough.
And it comes back down
to form the product.
Plus the enzyme.
Without the enzyme in there,
this hump would
be way, way up there.
Would be maybe a factor
of ten higher.
So this really lowers
it a lot.
Now we can start to solve
this mechanism.
And I forgot one arrow.
There which is the
arrow going back.
Which you usually don't
see, but we might as
well keep it there.
For the sake of completeness.
So what do we know?
We know that this intermediate
concentration is very small.
The enzyme concentration
itself is very small.
Intermediate is very small.
And it doesn't change
very much.
Not changing much.
So that means that we need
to use a steady state
approximation.
So let's write down
the rate for this
intermediate, d[ES]/dt.
It gets formed through
the forward process.
I'm going to put my brackets
back in because E and ES would
look the same otherwise.
Gets destroyed.
Through the backward ways.
And I'm going to use a steady
state approximation.
So I'm already going to start
adding steady state here every
time I see an intermediate.
Get it destroyed to
make products.
It gets recreated through
the backwards
reaction from the products.
And I'm going to set that equal
to zero for the steady
state approximation.
Now, we don't really
want to have this E
floating around here.
Because this is something that
is very hard to measure.
It's much easier to measure the
initial concentration of
the enzyme.
What you put in there, instead
of the amount that's
not being bound up.
So we're going to solve,
instead, in terms of [E] is
equal to [E]0 minus [ES], where
this is the initial
concentration and this
is the amount
that's binding substrate.
And this is the amount of
free enzyme here then.
And when you do that, and you
plug in here, and you plug in
here, you get your result.
Which is that [E] steady state,
[ES] steady state, is
this ratio. k1 times [S] plus k
minus two times the product
divided by k minus one plus k2
plus k1 times [S] plus k minus
two times the product, times
proportional to the initial
concentration of enzyme.
And then you can take your
steady state approximation for
the intermediate and plug it
back into your rate equation.
So the velocity, we defined
as the rate which is minus
d[S]/dt, which is k1 times [E]
times [S], this is the
destruction of the substrate
minus k minus one, times [ES]
steady state, the backwards
process.
So we put in, instead of this
[E] we put in [E] is equal to
[E]0 minus [ES]
steady state.
And then we put in for [ES]
steady state, we put in
what we found here.
We turn the crank
on the algebra.
And we find that the velocity,
then, is k1 k2 times the
substrate concentration.
Minus k minus one times k minus
two times the product
concentration.
The whole thing times the
initial enzyme concentration.
And then k minus one plus
k2 on the bottom.
Plus k1 [S] plus k minus
two times the product.
So, as I mentioned, this product
here usually just
floats away.
And so locally, where you're
doing the, and then it gets
used by the next step
in the cycle.
So this is pretty much zero.
We can pretty much
ignore this.
We can ignore this
guy here too.
Because it's not, you don't have
any steady state or an
equilibrium.
You have a steady state but not
an equilibrium situation.
And so in that case here, you
can rewrite this then as k1 k2
times the substrate times [E]0
divided by k minus one plus k2
plus k1 times the substrate.
And now we can look at these
experimental observations and
see whether they match
our mechanism.
If we can understand
something.
So let's look at the
initial rate.
Initial rate is supposed to be
proportional to the substrate.
So the initial rate, k1
k2 plus k1, if at
early times, plus one.
So the initial rate is going
to be, somehow I've got the
product missing here.
No, I got it backwards here.
This is not the initial rate.
This is the rate where
[S] is small.
The initial rate is when you
don't have any products made.
Or when the product
concentration is very low.
And because we're making the
assumption that the product
concentration is basically equal
to zero here, this is
basically the initial
rate here.
So by taking the product equal
to zero here, we're also
saying that this is the same
thing as the initial rate.
So this is what it
looks like here..
The initial rate here.
And this is, this, you rewrite
as v initial is equal to k2
times [S] times [E]0.
You divide by k1 up and down.
And you have this k minus one
plus k2 over k1 and then plus
[S] sitting down there.
And you define this ratio of
rates, k minus one plus k2
over k1 as the KM, the Michaelis
constant, by
definition.
And this is an interesting
ratio.
This is the rate, k minus one is
the rate of destroying the
enzyme substrate complex by
going back to the reactants.
k2 is the destruction
of the complex by
going to the product.
And k1's the creation
of the complex.
So this is the rate of
destruction of the complex
divided by the rate of creation
of the complex.
So if the rate of destruction of
the complex is much faster
than the rate of creation,
meaning that this is a large
number, then you're not going
to pile up any complex.
It's going to be destroyed
as soon as you create it.
So if KM is large, then the
concentration, [ES], is going
to be very small.
Compared to [E]0.
But if the rate of destruction
of the complex is small
compared to the rate of
creation, you create
complexes, you create complexes
but you don't keep
up in terms of destroying
them, in terms of making
products, or going back
to reactants.
And so you end up saturating
your enzyme.
Every enzyme ends up having
substrate bound to it.
So when KM is very small, then
[ES] goes to saturation.
Basically, when KM is very
small, then you're limited by
the rate, the second rate in
the process, of the enzyme
falling apart.
To form the product.
You have to wait until
that happens.
Because then the product
just floats away.
And that becomes your
rate limiting step.
Another way that you also will
see this written is as this,
then, is equal to, we'll define
k cat is equal to k2. k
cat times the enzyme
concentration times the
substrate, [E]0, divided by
KM plus but the substrate
concentration.
So let's look at a few
limiting cases then.
First limiting case is, suppose,
that [S] is large.
Let's take [S] to be much
larger than KM.
Because you look at the
denominator, and you see it's
this ratio of rates but there's
this concentration
that's important here.
So in one case KM is going to
dominate, and in the other
limiting case the substrate
concentration is going to dominate.
So let's say that the substrate
concentration dominates.
Meaning K sub M is small.
In which case we already saw.
If K sub M is small then
you reach saturation.
And in the equation, then, the
velocity, KM is small, [S] is
large, the [S]'s cancel out and
the velocity is equal to k
cat times the initial substrate
concentration.
Both of these are constants.
The velocity is constant.
And the rate is constant,
it's that limit up here.
That's experimentally seen.
And the rate is depending
on the initial substrate
concentration.
Initial enzyme concentration.
All the enzymes have a
substrate in there.
The more enzymes you have
to begin with, the more
intermediates you're going to
have, the faster you going to
make products.
And then it's going to depend
on this on the rate, k cat,
which is just k2, which is the
rate of formation of products.
That becomes the rate
limiting step here.
The other special case is if
substrate concentration is
very small compared to KM.
And in that case here, and the
other thing that we're going
to do is, we're going to,
because we now understand this
as this maximum rate up there,
we're going to call this v
max. k cat times [E]0, we're
going to call it v max.
And so when [S] is very small,
v, then, is equal to v max,
which is k cat times [E]0.
This is v max here now.
So we can rewrite this as v max
times substrate divided by
KM plus the substrate
concentration.
Another way of writing it.
Capital K.
v max times the substrate
concentration.
And we have KM plus [S].
But [S] is very small.
So we drop it.
And this is then proportional
to the substrate
concentration.
And then that's small substrate
concentration
compared to KM, we're
sitting right here.
Where it's linear, where
the rate is linear.
And there's a third place
on the graph which is
interesting.
Which is when the substrate
concentration is equal to KM.
In that case there, you plug [S]
equal to KM, and you end
up with the velocity then is
equal to v max divided by two.
So when [S] is equal to KM,
you are halfway up.
There's v max over two and
there's KM sitting here.
When [S] is equal to KM, you're
at v max over two.
And so enzymes, then, are
labeled by their KM's.
Because then it becomes very
important to know how strongly
they bind the substrate.
Sometimes you want the enzyme
to bind it very strongly.
Sometimes you don't, you
want it to be fleeting.
Depends on the role that
the enzyme plays.
Now there's a way to plot this
that extracts out these
important numbers.
k cat and KM.
And that's the Lineweaver-Burk
plot..
Lineweaver-Burk plot..
And I just looked up this
morning to see if Mr.
Lineweaver was still alive.
And as far as I can tell
he's still alive.
He was 97, in 2003.
So as of 2007 he was
still alive.
He's getting up there.
One of the most cited papers
that you have in your notes is
the in Jack's, was the paper
that showed how to go from
this curved line to a straight
line by plotting one over v
versus [S], instead
of v versus [S].
So if you take your equation and
massage it, one over v KM
over v max times [S], plus one
over v max, we haven't done
anything except rewrite the
equation in terms of one of v
versus one over [S].
So it becomes linear.
In one over [S], and there's
one over v sitting here.
And you get a straight line.
With an intercept here that's
one over v max.
And if you keep going,
extrapolate out, you get this
point here to be minus 1
over KM and the slope
is KM over v max.
And v max was equal to k cat
times [E]0, so you get k cat
out of this.
So it turned out to be
a very useful plot.
It's very easy to plot a
straight line, especially
before computers.
In the age of computers.
And the referees, there were
six referees that got this
paper and pretty much turned
it down because they didn't
think there was any new
chemistry in it.
Which is true, there's
no new chemistry.
It's just a way of rewriting
the plot.
But it was very important
nevertheless.
OK, any questions on catalysis?
Enzymes?
Arrhenius?
Alright, next time we'll
oscillating reactions and
recap the course.